2 le souvenir je dirais y en a
on disait de lui c'était un dieu vivant
ce n'est plus qu'un homme mort un nom
sur une plaque que l'on nettoie deux
fois par jour aux citrons ayrton senna
repose au cimetière de wimbee à sao
paulo sa ville natale 33 mois après sa
mort on y vient toujours se recueillir
et fleurir une tombe isolée des autres
à l'extérieur les marchands de souvenirs
se sont installés mais les touristes s'y
arrête de bonne grâce
je suis venu voir quelqu'un qui faisait
partie de ma famille c'est aussi fort
que ça pour moi au moment de sa mort je
l'étais premier devenir donc je suis là
j'ai été premier c'est fait sao paulo
mégalopole inconsolable la cité a perdu
son prince de la vitesse celui qui
brandissaient le drapeau brésilien à
chacune de ses victoires
senna le fils de bonne famille
tout un peuple par la neige en une
personnalité inclassable le mythe se
perpétue tout seul gérard you le peintre
de quartier passent des heures à
dessiner des voitures les voitures
d'ayrton sans certaines les collisions
principaux
vous voyez bien ce tableau il manque
quelque chose et je vais pas mettre
ayrton ici carrousel veux pas ici c'est
son absence c'est tout un mode artistes
amateurs ou professionnels photo bleeps
culture les objets se sont multipliés et
dans les fan club de sao paulo
on rencontre toujours ceux qui veulent
lui ressembler ceux qui sont
nostalgiques des hommes et des femmes
pour qui l'absence d'ayrton époux
présente que sa présence même
au même moment à des milliers de
kilomètres quelque part dans paris un
restaurant où l'on s'est réuni autre
lieu autre fan club
mais la motivation est la même
mais nos meilleurs jeunes existe depuis
six ans 450 adhérents dans toute la
france des rencontres une petite
publication des objets souvenirs épine
de postes
le passé en tant qu'adhérent parce que
là les ronciers recevoir je voulais
donner quelque chose à mon tour comme si
je voulais un peu rembourser tout ce
qu'a fait avec le faire pour moi enfin
tout ça pour ma façon
bien sûr le procès des mollahs ne le
fera pas revenir à la maison
fondation a créé l'institut rdc n'en
sont plus tout été prouvée le sucre le
champion du monde venir en aide aux
enfants pauvres du brésil trois
programmes d'action nutrition éducation
et sport une organisation caritative
dans cet immeuble puis tout est
coordonnée c'est ici que se trouve le
véritable héritage
je fais ce qu'il a désiré deux mois
avant l'accident
il m'a dit qu'il voulait des enfants un
risque
les enfants qui n'ont pas eu
l'opportunité qu'ils aillent dans sa vie
il voulait partager ça avec ses enfants
symbolisé cette demande de six décennies